cesium 137 is a radioactive tracer
element used to study upslope soil
erosion and downstream sedimentation it
has a half-life of approximately 30 days
so this half-life of 30 days this means
that if you were to start with let's say
if you were to start with two kilograms
of cesium 137 that 30 days later 30 days
later you're going to have one kilogram
of cesium 137 that the other kilogram
has decayed into other things
assume and if you waited another 30 days
you would have half a kilogram of
cesium-137
assume that the amount a in becquerels
of
cesium-137 in a soil sample is given by
the exponential function a is equal to c
times r to the t where t is the number
of days since the release of cesium-137
into the soil and c and r are unknown
constants so this bears some explaining
what is this becquerel business so
normally if i were to talk about the
amount of some element i'd probably be
thinking in terms of mass and i might
talk in terms of kilograms but some
people might also be referring to the
amount of this radioactive substance in
terms of the amount of radioactivity it
produces and becquerels is the
international unit of radioactivity
named after henry beckerel who
co-discovered radioactivity with marie
curie so
you could consider this the amount of
the amount of cesium-137 that causes a
becquerels of act of radioactivity but
either way we can just think of it as a
as a quantity but it's really the
quantity that causes a becquerels of
activity
so just to be clear the the
amount is given by the exponential
function a is equal to let me just
rewrite it a is equal to c times r
to the t power where t is the number of
days since the release of the cesium-137
in the soil and c and r are unknown
constants fair enough
so let's just be clear this is days
days since release in addition assume
that we know that the initial amount of
cesium-137 released in the soil is eight
becquerels is eight becquerels
solve for the unknown constants c and r
so the initial in the soil that's when t
is equal to zero when no days have
passed so we could say that the amount
at time zero well that's going to be
equal to c
times r to the 0 power which is just
going to be equal to c times 1 which is
equal to c and they tell us what a of 0
is they say a of 0 is 8 is 8 becquerels
so this is going to be equal to 8. so
our constant here the c is just going to
be equal to 8. what is the value of the
constant we could just write 8 right
over there then they ask us what is the
value so the value of the constant c is
8 what is the value of the constant r
round to the nearest thousandth
so we're starting with eight so a of
zero is eight how much are we going to
have after 30 days and the reason why
i'm picking 30 days is that is the
half-life of cesium-137
so a of 30 remember our t is in let me
just switch colors just for fun
remember t is in days so a of 30 so
after 30 days i'm going to this is if i
want to use this this this the formula
right over here if i wanted to use the
description of this exponential function
we already know that c is eight it's
going to be eight times r to the
thirtieth power which is going to be
equal to what
well if we started with eight 30 days
later we're going to have half as much
we're going to have 4 becquerels we're
going to have 4. and now we can use this
to solve for r so you have 8 times r to
the 30th power is equal to 4. divide
both sides by 8 you get r to the 30th
power is equal to 4 over 8 which is the
same thing as 1 half and then we can
take
the 1 30th we can raise both sides to
the 1 30th power
r to the 30th but then the one then then
you could think of it the 30th root of
that or raising that to the 1 30th power
that's just going to give us r
is equal to one half
to the
1 30th
power
and
that is something that's very hard to
compute in your head so i suggest you
use a calculator for that and they they
hint because we're going to round to the
nearest we're going to round to the
nearest thousandth so let's get a
calculator right out
and so we're talking about
one half
to the one over thirty power
one over thirty power
so
we get
zero point nine seven seven one five
nine nine keeps going but they tell us
to round to the nearest thousand so
0.977
0.9770.977
rounded to the nearest thousandth
and then they finally say how many
becquerels of cesium-137 remain in our
sample
150 days 150 days after its release in
the soil use the rounded value of r and
round this number to the nearest
hundredth so just to be clear we now
have our we already know c and r we know
that the amount of cesium 137
in becquerels as a function of time in
days is going to be equal to
eight
times
0.977
to the t power where t is the number of
days that have passed and they're
essentially saying well how much do we
have left after 150 days so they want us
to calculate is what is a
of 150 well that's going to be 8 times
0.977
to the
150th pow to the 150th power and so
clearly we need a calculator for this
so let's calculate that so it's going to
be 8 times and they tell us to use our
rounded value of r not the exact value
of r so it's going to be 8 times
0.976
to the
150th
power
and that gets us
point and they want us to round to the
nearest hundredth 0.24
zero point
0.24 is in 0.24 becquerels is kind of
the radioactivity level of the cesium
137 that we have left over
now one interesting thing is they they
asked us to use the rounded value of r
so we use the rounded value of r but you
could because this right over here is a
multiple of 30 you could actually not
too different in a not too difficult of
a way find out the exact value that's
left over and actually you don't even
need a calculator for it i encourage you
to pause your video and try to think
about that find the exact value
well instead of writing
0.977 let's write a of t
as being equal to 8
times
r this is an approximate value for r if
we wanted to be a little more exact we
can say that our r is one half
to the one thirtieth
power and we're going to raise that
we're gonna raise that to the t power or
we could say a of t
is equal to 8
times one half to the t over 30 power if
we raise something to an exponent and
then raise that to an exponent we can
take the product of those exponents so
that's one half to the t over 30 power
let me actually do that in another color
let me do that yellow so that's eight
times one half
to the
one half to the t
over thirty power
one half to the t over thirty power and
actually i don't need this i don't need
this parentheses right over here this is
another way to describe a of t so what
is a of 150 so a
of 150
is going to be equal to eight
times
one half
to the 150 over thirty well that's just
five one half
to the fifth power well what's one half
to the fifth power
that is one to the fifth over two to the
fifth or one over thirty-two
so this right over here is one over
thirty-two which is equal to eight over
thirty-two
eight
over
thirty-two
which is equal to
one over four which is equal to 1 over 4
or 0.25 or 0.25
so our using our approximation for r we
got 0.24 when we rounded to the 150th
power so that's using our approximation
a lot we're multiplying we're taking 150
of these and multiplying by by
multiplying them together but it's not
too far off of what the real value is
and they asked us to use the rounded
value but if we'd use the the the
precise value the actual value we would
have gotten
0.0.25 becquerels would be left over